COMMITTEE HEARING WE ARE
CONTINUING TO REQUIRE THE MAST
BE WORN BY EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
AND INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
BUILDING TUESDAY. IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC THIS IS A
IN HERE IN THE ROOM IF ANYONE
LIKE TO TEST FOUND A BILL PLEASE
LISTEN FOR MY PROMPT TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE
DONE TESTIFYINGA RETURN YOUR
SEATS. FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES YOU
WE ARE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON THIS
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TELEVISION. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO
WHEN THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTED FOR IT FALLING ON
BEGINS THE PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST ON YOUR ON AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IF YOU ARE A PRIMARY WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE. WILL NEED
TO MEET YOUR DEVICE UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT 916-319-3958
AND MY STAFF WILL HELP YOU THERE
. WE ALSO ACCEPT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE CONTINUE USING THE
METHODS TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS. SO WE WILL NOT
COVER THE GROUND RULES FOR THE
APPROPRIATE CONDUCT. ASSEMBLY
HAS EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE-
COMMITTEE AND FLOOR PROCEDURE AS
THE LAST FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED SUCH
CONTACT MAY CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE
REMOVING A MASK REFUSING TO PUT
IT BACK ON TALKING OR MAKING
LOUD NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING ALLOWED THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER
THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED. EXTENDED
DISCUSSIONS OF MATTERS THAT
RELATE TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR BILL OR ANY OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO ADDRESS ANY
DOOR DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS MY OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WOULD DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT THE CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS
MAY RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORDS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND THE
NATURE OF THE DESTRUCTIVE
CONDUCT I MAY TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING- IF THE
PRODUCT DOES NOT STOP I REQUEST
THE ASSISTANCE FROM THE
SERGEANTS IN A SCORE IN THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. OKAY SO TODAY WE HAVE
SIX ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY WE
WILL HEAR ALL BILLS IN ORDER
SHOWN ON OUR AGENDA. UNLESS
OTHERWISE NOTED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM WILL BE PRESENTING AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. WE
WILL TAKE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION OF EACH
BILL THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THE NAME
OF THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
POSITION ON THE BILL- READ DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM BUT WILL OPERATE
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. IN OUR FIRST
BILL IS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIX
SEVEN TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ONE OF SET OFF BY-
EMPHASIZING THAT THIS BILL IS
VOLUNTARY HAVE PERMISSIVE OUT
THERE THE BILL ESTABLISHES AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
GRANTS TO LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO FACILITATE THE CONVERSION OF.
MUNICIPALLY OWNED GOLF COURSES
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND OPEN
SPACE. ABOUT WE NOW HAVE-
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT NUMBERS AND THIS
CYCLE ARE VERY SCARY IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WHERE
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL SPACE TO
BUILD. WE HAVE DONE THE
CONVERSIONS WE HAVE SPLIT THE
LOTS- WE HAVE BUILT UP WHERE WE
COULD- AND BROWNFIELDS AND GOLF
COURSES ARE SOME OF THE ONLY
PLACES WE HAVE LEFT OUR GOLF
COURSES SUBSIDIZED BY THE
TAXPAYERS- BUT WE HAVE A SMALL
BUDGET AND SO THE REALITIES OF
OURSELVES WE CAN DO THIS
WITHOUT- ADDITIONAL HELP AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE. THIS HELPS.
OUT THERE. I'M NOT AN ATTACK ON
A GOLF BUT RATHER JUST GIVING
AGENCIES AND OTHER TOOL. TO
THINK OUTSIDE THE FULL BOX- TO
TRY TO ADDRESS BOTH NEEDS OF
HEALTH IN AN OPEN SPACE. OUT
THERE WHEN IF IT'S THEIR
COMMUNITY AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS NOT THAT ALL COMMUNITIES
AND RESPECTFUL OF THAT AND JUST
TRYING TO CREATE. I THINK A
MODEST PROGRAM IN THE TOOL KIT
AS HE TRIED TO YOU KNOW ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING ISSUES ACROSS. THE
STATE- AS WELL WE HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES SO I WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS SOARED AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OPERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A LIST BOTH HANDS
BURKE- TO BE ON THE PHONE AS
WELL AS- DAVID BARBOSA. YES TERM
HERE THIS IS A BOOK ABOUT HIM
BURKE PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR MOVING
THIS FORWARD- MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH HANDS BURKE I CO
FOUNDED AND RUN THE YES IN MY
BACKYARD OR NIMBY. GROUP FOR
ORANGE COUNTY- AND WE ARE REALLY
FACED WITH THE SAME- TYPE OF
CONSTRAINTS THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHE IS COMMUNITY IS AS WELL- WE
HAVE CITIES THAT HAVE- YOU KNOW
LARGELY THINK OF THEMSELVES AS
BILLS OUCH DON'T HAVE- THE SITES
TO ACCOMMODATE THE RENO
PARTICULARLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND YET HERE WE HAVE A
GREAT RESOURCE IN PUBLICLY OWNED
LANDS- WHICH IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS THAT WE CAN BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND REDUCE
THE COST. PER DOOR IS TO USE
CITY ON SITE. I ANOTHER BALLPARK
MAKE FOR GREAT OPPORTUNITIES AS
THAT THEIR LARGE PARCELS AND SO
WE CAN INTEGRATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN THE LARGER HOUSING
AND OPEN SPACE PLANS TO CREATE
NEW COMMUNITIES AND NEW
NEIGHBORHOODS- RIGHT NOW CITIES
ARE OFTEN LEFT WITH YOU KNOW
SORT OF THE REMNANT PARCELS IN
AN INDUSTRIAL DOWN THAT ARE AWAY
FROM. OUR EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
AREAS BUT ALL COURSES IN CITIES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
EDEVELOPED REALLY PROVIDE. AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE-
YOU KNOW MIXED USE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ACCEPTING NEIGHBORHOOD
SERVING RETAIL- OPEN SPACE. BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF PLANNING THAT
MUST BE DONE TO GET COMMUNITY
BUY IN AND SUPPORT. AND SO THE
GRANT PROGRAM LIKE BATES COULD
ENABLE A CITY WHO'S LOOKING TO
AGAIN VOLUNTARILY- HAVE A LOOK
AT REDEVELOPING YOUR CALL COURTS
TO HELP PAY FOR THINGS LIKE.
RENDERING THE PIE SERVED AS A
PLANNING COMMISSIONER IN MY OWN
CITY FOR THREE YEARS. AND I KNOW
THAT THE PROJECT BUT THE CITY
COUNCIL HAS THE MOST DIFFICULTY
MOVING FORWARD ARE THE ONES FOR
WHICH FOLKS FELT. THEY EITHER
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT OR THEY
WEREN'T INFORMED AND THIS
PROGRAM WOULD REALLY HELP EASE
THE BUDGET. FOR A CITY THAT
WANTED TO CONSIDER- PURSUING A
PROJECT LIKE THIS. AND LAUGHING
JUST THAT WE WERE HAVE ASK
OURSELVES WE WANT TO GIVE OUR
PUBLIC RESOURCES. WE WANT PUBLIC
LAND TO BE USED TO SUBSIDIZE AN
EXPENSIVE HOBBY OF A FEW PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN A TOWN OF
LESS THEIR GOLFERS DON'T GET
ACCESS TO THIS OPEN SPACE. OR DO
WE WANT TO USE. OUR PUBLIC
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MANY PEOPLE.
INCLUDING PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
SHUT OUT OF OPPORTUNITY
COMMUNITIES- AND THAT THESE GOLF
COURSES REALLY DO OPTION. EXCUSE
ME THEY DO OFFER A WONDERFUL
OPTION FOR CITY BETTER
INTERESTED IN PICKING THEM UP.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND AGAIN JUST THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER WORK ON
THAT AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL
SUPPORT. WITHOUT BURKE CHIU
ADDED TOOL TO THE TOOLBOX. GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER HANDS BURKE
WELL NOW WILL IS. LOOKING FOR
DAVID BARBOSA PLEASE. HELLO YEAH
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DAVID BARBOZA AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND RESEARCH
FOR ABUNDANT HOUSING LA A PRO
HOUSING NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO HELP
SOLVE SOMETHING CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SINCE. ABUNDANT HOUSING
LA IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB SIX
SEVEN TWO. AB SIX SEVEN THROUGH
THE PROVIDE GRANTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENTER INTO
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS TO
CONVERT PUBLICLY ON GOLF COURSE
ISN'T A HOUSING PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE OPEN SPACE WITH AT
LEAST 25% OF THE NEW HOMES
NEEDING TO BE AFFORDABLE TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS- AT LEAST 15%
OF THE DEVELOPMENT WOULD HAVE TO
BE PRESERVED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE OPEN SPACE. I KNOW MORE
THAN THAN A THIRD OF THE
DEVELOPMENT COULD BE FOR NON
RESIDENTIAL USE. OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO GRAPPLE WITH THE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS SB
SIX SEVEN TWO ADDRESSES TWO KEY
STRATEGIES TO STABILIZE HOME
PRICES FIRSTLY IT WOULD INCREASE
THE SUPPLY OF MARKET RATE HOMES
WITH NO DISPLACEMENT OF EXISTING
RESIDENTS TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE AND PUT DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON HOUSING PRICES.
SECONDLY IT WOULD INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF INCOME RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO PROVIDE
MORE IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS LOCAL DECLINES
IN POPULARITY AB SIX SEVENTY TWO
CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROMOTE
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS THAT
BRING US CLOSER TO THE GOALS OF
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY. AND
APPROVED ACCESS TO TRULY PUBLIC
OPEN SPACE BE RESPECTFUL BUT YOU
pTHANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BOSER
APPROACHES MOVING ALONG- BUT WE
WILL HAVE OUR OPPOSITION THE
SECOND BUT I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. SO. MR MACDONELL.ADWARE THERE. I RECORD HERE
LACKEY. WACKY HERE BLOOM. BOOM
HERE IN ORDER. BOERNER HORVATH
HERE RAMOS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS ABOUT YELP YELP
HAVE A QUORUM I WOULD LIKE TO GO
ON WITH THEIR OPPOSITION TO AB
SIX SEVENTY TWO- I'M LOOKING FOR
JOE HOUSTON OR CRAIG KESSLER
PLEASE. HELLO THIS IS JOE
HOUSTON WELCOME- CHAIRPERSON AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT MY NAME IS
JOE HOUSTON HI I'M THE CEO OF
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GOLF
ASSOCIATION AND WHILE WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
WHICH SINGLED OUT PUBLIC GOLF
COURSES. THAT THEY PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND OUR FOUNDATION YOUTH ON
COURSE HAS THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
YOUTH MEMBERS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE AND WE ALSO PLAY A ROLE TO
SUPPORT THE ENTIRE INTEREST OF
THE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
GOLFERS IN CALIFORNIA. I
ORGANIZATIONS VISION IS TO
ENSURE THE GAME IS INCLUSIVE AND
ACCEPTABLE AND ALSO TO PROVIDE
LIFE CHANGING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DESERVING YOUTH. EXISTENCE THE
PUBLIC MUNICIPAL GOLF COURSES
ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO OUR
EFFORTS. TODAY I WANT TO PROVIDE
THREE QUICK POINTS. FIRST GOLF
PROVIDES TREMENDOUS VALUE TO OUR
SOCIETY INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE GAME OF GOLF IS REALLY
UNIQUE IN THE VALUES AND LEFT OF
THAT IMPRESSES UPON PEOPLE WHAT
OTHER SPORT HAVE THE PLAYER CALL
PENALTY ON THEMSELVES. GOLF
REWARD THE VALUE OF HARD WORK
AND ABILITY RECOVER FROM
MISTAKES AND TEACH A GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE ENVIRONMENT TO
LEAVE THE COURSE BETTER THAN YOU
FOUND IT. ALL THESE SKILLS
TRANSCEND THE GAME AND THEY
PLAYED A LIFE IN GENERAL. IT THE
GAME OF GOLF ALSO PROVIDE THE
PLATFORM TO GIVE BACK WHERE MANY
OF OUR PUBLIC FACILITIES
PROVIDE. A FOUNDATION TO HELP
RAISE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL CHARITIES. SECOND OF ALL
THE GAME OF GOLF IS GROWING. NOW
IF YOU'RE A GOLFER YOU KNOW IT'S
BEEN MUCH HARDER TO GET IT AT
TEATIME AT A PUBLIC GOLF COURSE
THE LAST TWO YEARS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE AROUND UP. ARE UP IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY
PERCENT. YOUTH ON COURSE ROUNDS
HAVE DOUBLED IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE HELP SUBSIDIZE MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ROUNDS FOR
DESERVING KIDS. AND THEY HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO SOCIALIZE AND
LEARN THE VALUES OF THE GAME
THAT HELP THEM IN THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES AND THEY DO THIS IN
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND WITH
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
IN PLACE. TO THIS IS NOT TIME TO
INCENTIVIZE THE CLOSURE OF GOLF.
IN THIRD ISN'T IT DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION. AND THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THE GAME HAVE CHANGED THEY'VE
CHANGED FOR THE BETTER. IT'S
VERY EVIDENT IF YOU LOOK AND YOU
GO TO A PUBLIC GOLF COURSE AND
IT'S EVEN MORE EVIDENT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT JUNIOR GOLFERS. OUR DATA
SHOWS THAT THE GAME OF GOLF IS
GROWING FASTEST AMONGST PEOPLE
OF COLOR. JUNIORS AND WOMEN.
YOUTH ON COURSE TO HELP DRIVE
THE CENTER AND T. G. A. REACH
PROGRAM THAT'S NEW HELPS PROVIDE
GRANTS TO PUBLIC COURSES TO HELP
PROMOTE DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
THERE'S A LOT OF MOMENTUM IN
THIS AREA AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO MAKE PROGRESS. AND CLOSELY
INVOLVED I WANT THE OUR
ORGANIZATION WORKS COLLABORATIVE
LEE WITH OTHER ORGANIZATION
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE-
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR GOLF
INCLUDE THE FPGA GOLF COURSE
OWNERS SUPERINTENDENTS. AND-OTHER INDUSTRY ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO ALL STAND UNITED IN THE
PROPOSITION AND I'VE BEEN
INFORMED ALSO THAT THERE'S AT
LEAST TWELVE ORGANIZATION
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION THAT
WEREN'T. INCLUDED IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT THAT INCLUDED
SOME REPRESENTATIONS FROM.
LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN ONE
ASIAN AMERICANS AND- FILIPINO
GOLF CLUBS AND ORGANIZATIONS AND
WE DO HOPE THAT THEIR VOICES ARE
ALSO HEARD. SO WE BELIEVE THIS
IS NOT THE TIME TO INCENTIVIZE
THE CLOSURE OF GOLF COURSES AND
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NEXUS CRAIG KESSLER I
BELIEVE. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON-
GREG KESSLER REPRESENTING THE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GOLF
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE ALSO
ALLIED WITH A NUMBER OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING OUR OUR
FRIENDS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN THE CALIFORNIA WATCH FOOTBALL
I'M IN ADDRESSING VERY SPECIFIC
THINGS. FIRST WITH RESPECT TO
EXISTING LAW NO WE'RE IN THIS
DISCUSSION FROM THE AUTHOR OR
THAT ALISON IS THERE ANYTHING
ABOUT THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THE
CONVERSION OF PUBLICLY ON GOLF
COURSES THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
AS ENVISIONED BY AB SIX SEVENTY
TWO WOULD VIOLATE THE PARK
PRESERVATION ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS ONLY THREE
YEARS YOUNGER SURPLUS LAND ACT.
THAT'S PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE
CHAPTER TWO POINT FIVE IT'S VERY
LIKELY THE LEAD TO YEARS OF
LITIGATION WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL
LIKELY RESULT EXPECTED
NULLIFICATION OF EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY TWO. THE REASON THAT THE
STAFF ANALYSIS POSITS THE
CONCLUSION THAT THERE IS NOT
SUBSTANTIAL PRECEDENT FOR
CONVERSION OF GOLF COURSES TO
OTHER USES IS PRECISELY BECAUSE
THE PRODUCT PRESERVATION ACT HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN SEEN AS A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF DOING THAT
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. WITH
RESPECT TO FISCAL SPOKE BACK THE
MOST RECENT DRAFT OF THE BILL
WAS DROPPED A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PRICE TAG TO THE PRIOR
SEPTEMBER NINTH STRAPPED AS NOW%
DRAFTED THE BILL GIVES NO IDEA
OF THE SCOPE OF THE BILL'S
INTENTIONS. THIS IS WE I MIGHT
ADD MANY OF THE MUNICIPALITIES
ALONG IS GOLF COURSES THANK
LIKELY THE PARK PRESERVATION ACT
APPLIES ANY PROCEEDS FROM
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS BASIC MORE
THAN EATEN UP BY THE PARK
PRESERVATION ACT REQUIREMENT.
THAT PROCEEDS OF THE TRANSACTION
BE USED TO ACQUIRE SUBSTITUTE
PARK LAND FACILITIES FOR USE AS
THE AXE STATE QUOTE BY GENERALLY
TE SAME PERSON HE USED EXISTING
PARK LAND AND FACILITIES
ALTHOUGH MANY AND OFTEN VERY
INTERPRET THAT TO MEAN THAT A
RECREATIONAL USE OTHER THAN GOLF
SATISFIES THE REQUIREMENTS.
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS DOES NOT IN OTHER
WORDS A GOLF COURSE HAS BEEN
MANY HAVE CAN BE CHANGED INTO
ANOTHER RECREATIONAL. USE THIS
BILL THAT YOU PROPOSED THAT
HUNDRED CURRENT LAW. RICHEST TO
THE ACT OF PERFORMANCE OF THE
GOD IN WHICH- THE AUTHOR STATES
THE NATIONAL GUARD FOUNDATION.
TO SIX TO THAT SIX INVOLVED A
DECLINING. THIS IS JUST FLAT NOT
TRUE IN THIS THIS THEIR
MATERIALS PICK DATA CON. THE
SUCCESS- PRECISE OPTED OF WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN PUTTING OUT FOR
YEARS NATIONAL GOLF FOUNDATION
YESTERDAY SUBMITTED A LETTER TO
THIS COMMITTEE. THAT PROVIDES
DATA EVIDENCE IF YOU WILL BUT
THE FACT THE GOLF NATIONALLY HAS
GROWN EVERY YEAR FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS AND XCELERATED PACE
IN THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. AGAIN I WOULD AGREE WITH
JOE AT ONE PLACE OFF THE OFFICE
DISTRICT NUMBERS NAY WITH IT
YOUR BIGGEST PROBLEM IS SECURING
A TEE TIME. WITH RESPECT THE
JOBS HOUSING IMBALANCE IS DUSTY
POPULATED URBAN. AREAS THE
AUTHOR STATES THAT. THE IDEAL
SIZE FOR COME WITH THE URBAN AIR
SO THEY CAN GET IN. AND WE'RE OF
NEARBY RESIDENTS ARE LIMITED
OPEN SPACE. ABOUT THE
SPECIFICATION OF GOLF COURSES
QUALIFYING CREEPY SIX SEVENTY
TWO CONVERSION MUST BE LOCATED
IN DENSELY POPULATED AREAS HAS
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE ACT IN ITS
LATEST ITERATION. IS
TRANSLITERATION THEY CAN BE
LOCATED ANYWHERE THE BILL LET'S
START OUT OF THE SAPPER HOUSING
SHORTAGE ALL OF KNOWLEDGE IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES EXECUTE
THIS. IS NOW ANYTHING BUT THAT.
IN WRAPPING UP A CONCLUDING THIS
RUSH TO YOUR BILL IS RIDDLED
WITH FALSE PROMISES IT OPEN
ENDED COMMITMENTS IN INTERNAL
CONTRADICTIONS IT CREATES MYRIAD
PROBLEMS PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO OPEN SPACE IN THOSE
PRECISELY THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE LONG BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
PARK FOR ESTABLISHING A
OTHER SPECIALIZED RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITY THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER
IS ANY ACTIVE RECREATIONAL
ACTIVITY BOB IS ONE OF THEM SO
WAS BASEBALL STORES A QUESTION
SAYS SO IS PUBLIC SWIMMING POOL
SO WITH EVERY ALMOST EVERY PARK
LAND FUNCTION EXCEPT CLEAR OPEN
SPACE. THEY'RE ALL USED BY
ASKING LIMITED PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THEM AND GOLF IS GOLF IS
ACTUALLY MORE HIGHLY UTILIZED
ANY OF THE OTHERS FINISHES
WANTED EVERYONE REPORT SO THIS
IS THIS PROVIDED VERY LITTLE THE
ACTUAL PROBLEM IT PURPORTS TO
SOLVE REPORTS TO SOLVE. MY DESK
YOU'RE OUR BEST GUESS. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OUR ARE PRETTY GREAT
YOU COULD TAKE THE NOT HUNDRED
GOT. AND SANTA MONICA MOUNTAIN
YOU THAT'S WHAT YOU JUST THINK
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION APPRECIATE
THAT. OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION YOU CAN CALL IN FIRST
OF ALL IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE AUDITORIUM. THEY WANT TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL SAYING NONE
OPERATOR OF I'M LOOKING FOR A
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION AND SUPPORT
YOU THERE'S ONE ALL THEY NEED TO
DO IS GIVE US THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU TO STATE
YOUR POSITION ON A. B. SIX
SEVENTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BETTER THIS
TIME WE HAVE. THIRTEEN LINES IN
Q. FIRST WE HAVE LINE THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS A-
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS WITH THE
BILL ARE QUITE A WITH MY HELP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF- IN
THE PARK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER- ONE NINETEEN ONE
NINE. GEORGE MARC CCO FIRST
SILICON VALLEY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SIX SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. LINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR. LINE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE TWENTY TWO ZERO. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON LISA
VS IN YOUR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR WOMEN'S
GOLF COUNCIL AND I'M A RESIDENT
OF PACIFICA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY FOUR. YES THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY
NAME'S TOM ADDIS FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PGA AND OUR
ASSOCIATIONS IS STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO AB SIX SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE LINE THIRTY
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY. THE GOOD
AFTERNOON BLENDED NOT SUBJECTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL GOLFERS
ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. NINE THIRTEEN ONE THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE MARC CONNELLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA GOLF COURSE
OWNERS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE GOLF COURSE SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THE HIGH LOW DESERT AND WE
STAND STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER. BLIND. TWENTY SIX TWO
SIX. HI MY NAME IS HERE WRITER
AND I'M A RESIDENT L. A. COUNTY
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I HAVE CREATED A COMMUNITY
PLAN FOR PENN MARC OFF OR
ANYTHING LONG BEACH LET'S COUNTY
. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. M. LINE
TWENTY NINE TO NINE. I'VE JUST
BEEN A MOTHER NOT- THE FOUNDER
OF LATINO GOLFERS ASSOCIATION
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS IN
L. A. COUNTY WAS RAISED IN
PUBLIC HOUSING AND WE OPPOSE.
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. BLIND TWENTY ONE.
JEFF JOHNSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GOLF COURSE SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSOCIATION I REPRESENT OVER TWO
THOUSAND INDUSTRY MEMBERS AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE STRONG IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY TWO. THANK
YOU CALLER. NINE TWENTY TWO. KIM
FARREN AS WELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GOLF COURSE
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER TWO THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. WELL I AM
THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE. RICHARD
HARRIS WITH CARE FRANCISCO
PUBLIC GOLF ALLIANCE. NOT A- BIG
GAP BEFORE SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
PLUS MEMBERS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER. WELL I AM THIRTY
SEVEN. HAVE A MOM WITH NON UNION
B. WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EXPENDITURE. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
. FINE. THIRTY SIX THREE SIX. I
APPOINTED MARTIN NOMAN A THE
SUMMER DAIGNEAULT AND ABOUT HALF
OF THE MILLIONS OF CELLS IN MY
BODY- I'VE BEEN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE STILL. THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER. NINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO
SEVEN. THIS IS JORDAN FINALLY
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN WHICH
REPRESENTS THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
HOSPITALITY WORKERS AND SEVEN
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA AWAY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY NINE
THREE NINE. HELLO IT OPERATES
FROM BERKELEY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. LINE FORTY FOUR
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
THIS IS EVERY MORE MINISTER
APPOINTMENT CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL FOR BETTER HEALTH TO
CALL ALSO KNOWN AS DOCTORS
ORDERS PLAY GOLFS AND WE
STRONGLY AND HEART COOLEY OPPOSE
SB SIX SEVEN TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINES
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. YES MR OF
THE SUMMER VOEPEL. SO I'M NOT
NECESSARILY A QUESTION BUT A
COMMENT IF I MAY MADAM CHAIR YES
ALL RIGHT. SO I SPENT THIRTY
NINE YEARS IN THE INSURANCE
BUSINESS ENSURING GOLF COURSES.
AND DEVELOPERS SO HERE IS MY
PERSONAL OPINION AS AN INDUSTRY
EXPERT WELL WAIT A MINUTE COMMA.
AT LEAST I THINK I'M AN INDUSTRY
EXPERT OKAY. SO HERE'S WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. IN THIS BILL I
GREATLY RESPECT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA I KNOW YOUR INTENT IT IS
PURE IT IS GOOD BUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. OUR
THIS. SO YOU GOTTA TAKE A GOLF
COURSE. AND A DEVELOPER WILL BE
WORKING TO DEAL. WITH THE GOLF
COURSE IN ORDER TO PURCHASE 60%
OF IT. OKAY AND THE 25% THAT
SUPPOSED TO BE INCLUSIONARY
ZONING FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN THE BACK
OF THE BUS THEY'RE GONNA BE
STACKED UP WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
A VIEW OF THE GOLF COURSE AND-
THE RICH PEOPLE. MULTI
MILLIONAIRES WILL BE ON THE GOLF
COURSE. OKAY I'D LIKE TO JOIN A
GROUP BUT THEN I DON'T THINK I
QUALIFY. SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
SIXTY FORTY HERE. THE OTHER
THING IS. YOU'LL LOSE. 30% OF
YOUR GOLF COURSES BASICALLY
BECAUSE THERE'S MANY GOLF
COURSES BECAUSE OF INSURED ON
THAT ARE GOING BROKE OR AREN'T
IN GOOD SHAPE OR FOR WHATEVER
REASON MANY TIMES THE GOLF
COURSES OWNED BY A FAMILY AND
THE MATRIARCH OF THE FAMILY DIES
AND THE KIDS JUST WANT THE MONEY
. SO THEY'LL BE A- TURNOVER OF
GOLF COURSES HERE SO THE REASON
MY COLLEAGUES YOU'RE HEARING
THIS OPPOSITION IS THEY EITHER
SENSE WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN OR
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
. MADAM CHAIR THAT IS MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND TO GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN FOR ANOTHER FOR ANOTHER
ROUND OF- OF HEARINGS- I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL- BUT I'M
DOING SO VERY CAUTIOUSLY AND I'M
RESERVING MY RIGHT TO VOTE
AGAINST IT WHEN IT- IF AND WHEN
IT COMES TO THE FLOOR- I THINK.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CONCERN I
HAVE IS I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE PICKING THE WINNERS AND
LOSERS HERE FLAG OFF COURSES AND
WHY NOT BSEBALL DIAMONDS AND
SOCCER FIELDS AND ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS. MENTIONED EQUESTRIAN
USES- I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
DIFFERENT ABOUT A GOLF COURSE-
AS A RECREATIONAL USE AS OPEN
SPACE- COMPARED TO SOME OF THOSE
OTHER. USES I DO UNDERSTAND- THE
NEED. TO IDENTIFY PLACES WHERE
WE CAN BUILD HOUSING AND I THINK
THAT'S A VERY PRESSING AND
IMPORTANT NEED AND I'VE-
PROBABLY GONNA HAVE SOME
LEGISLATION ON MY OWN ON THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON A PROPOSAL
OR TO- IN IN MY DISTRICT. TO
CONVERT. OF A SOME UNDER
UTILIZED TO- PROPERTIES TO-
HOUSING AND PARTICULARLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- FIVE I THINK
IT'S GOOD THAT THIS- IS LOCALLY
FOCUSED IT'S UP TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS BUT I THINK-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL MAKES A
GOOD POINT IN SAYING THAT-
ULTIMATELY IF WE OPEN UP THE
STORE DEVELOPERS WILL START TO-
DRIVE THE PROCESS AND YOU KNOW
IDENTIFY SPACES WHERE THEY THINK
THEY CAN BENEFIT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN
FIND A WAY TO- AT ACHIEVE SOME
ADDITIONAL REVENUE AND I JUST.
QUESTION IF WE WANT TO OPEN UP
THAT PANDORA'S BOX AND- OPEN UP
THESE- FOR THE MOST PART WHILE
PRESERVING BUT BY THE WAY I
DON'T HAVE ANY GOLF COURSES- NOT
THE CITY I LIVE AND- OF. PUBLIC
GOLF COURSES IN THE CITY I LIVE
IN AND I THINK IN MY AN ENTIRE
DISTRICT WHICH MIGHT SURPRISE
SOME PEOPLE- I DO HAVE A LOT OF
OUT OF IT- PRIVATE YOU. EXCUSE
ME PUBLIC USE GOLFERS- AND I
THINK I HEARD FROM BOTH OF THEM
OFF WHEN THAT PARTICULARLY WHEN
THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE FILM
WAS- WHAT WAS BEING DISCUSSED
PUBLICLY- THERE IS A LOT OF
CONCERN OUT THERE- IN THE GOLFER
WORLD AND CALL FOR WORLD MAY. BE
YOU KNOW A RELATIVE MINORITY IN
THE OVERALL- SPORTS AREA BUT- I
DON'T SEE WHY THAT MEANS THE-
GOLF COURSES SHOULD HAVE ANY
LESS PROTECTION WERE A BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY. THANK YOU
SO EVER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE SEEING NONE THAT
IS OUR MOTION. RULERS THE SECOND
ONE KERRIER MOTION THE SECOND
AND THEN- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES I WANT TO VERIFY FOR
THE RECORD THING THAT I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MET- MEN
MEN THANK YOU SHAPE THE
COMMITTEES HELP ON THIS- I HAVE
SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
CITY OF BELL GARDENS ONE
BASEBALL FIELD AND ONE MANY MANY
ACRES GOLF PERSON BUNCH OF
BROWNFIELDS I WEALTHY WORKING TO
TRY TO CLEAN UP AND CONVERT TO
BETTER USE. OUT THERE ARE AND IT
DOES NOT FROM COMMUNITIES IT'S
FOR COMMUNITIES TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION IF IT'S FOR THEM-
IT'S MODEST IT'S FOR COMMUNITIES
TO SOMETIMES ON HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO ENGAGE IN THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS OUT THERE. I HAVE.
GOOGLE FOR CORE WITHIN A MILE OF
EACH OTHER ON THE SAME STREET
ACTUALLY IN ONE- IS NOT
SUBSIDIZED THEY'RE BOTH PUBLICLY
ON ONE- MAKE A PROFIT AND THE
OTHER ONE IS DEFINITELY VERY
MUCH OF THE DAY IF AND I THINK
WHEN WE HAVE SITUATIONS LIKE
THAT MAYBE WE COULD START
THINKING ABOUT. ABOUT THAT YOU
STILL HAVE A SPACE TO ALLOW
GOLFERS TO PLAY THEN MAYBE WE
COULD ALSO TRY SOMETHING ELSE
AND SO- IT'S MODESTUS ONE TOOL
IN THE- TOOL KIT I LOOK FORWARD
TO ALL OF BILLS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SEE ON HOUSING THIS YEAR. OUT
THEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S SEE HERE- I JUST HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA THANK YOU FOR. WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE YOU
CHANGE THE BILL FROM A MANDATE.
TO AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM. WHICH
ALLEVIATES THE ISSUE OF WHETHER
THIS AUTHORITIES APPROPRIATE FOR
EVERY CHIP JURISDICTION. AS WE
KNOW SOME CITIES AND COUNTIES
MAY SEE THIS IS AN ATTRACTIVE
WAY TO DEVELOP NEW HOUSING. WITH
YOUR EFFORTS THOSE CITIES
COUNCILS AND- COUNTY BOARDS CAN
WEIGH THE INTEREST OF THE
RESIDENTS IN DECIDING WHETHER
THIS IS A VERY. USEFUL TOOL. I
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO HAVE STAFF
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH A CD
REGARDING POTENTIAL OVERLAP WITH
THE SIR PLAN. SURPLUS LANDS ACT.
AS YOUR BILL MOVES FORWARD. WITH
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY. OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY. LACKEY NOW BLOOM. BLOOM
HI BOERNER HORVATH. RAMOS
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL YEAH I'M SORRY AS RUSSIAN
. VOEPEL NOW. THE MORE I GET IT
WILL IT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPENER FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO- A BEAST. SIX THIRTY
TWO- SO SHOULD I DO NEXT. YEAH
WHAT DO SIX CITY TO BLOOM. YOU.
KNOW WE. YOU CAN BE THANK YOU
AND A GOOD MORE AGAIN A GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN THAT MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT A. B. SIX EIGHTY TO A
MEASURE TO INCENTIVIZE CO
HOUSING APARTMENTS AND ALSO
PLEASE TO ACCEPT- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OF THANKS COMMITTEE
FOR ITS WORK ON THIS BILL. A CO
HOUSING ALSO KNOWN AS COMMUNAL
LIVING IS TYPICALLY MADE UP OF
UNITS THAT ARE SMALLER THAN FOUR
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET- AND THEY
ALSO TYPICALLY OFFER A SHARED
KITCHEN AND DINING AREA
SOMETIMES OTHER- I SHARED
AMENITIES- AND THEY ARE AGAIN
TYPICALLY MORE AFFORDABLE THAN
THE AVERAGE STUDIO OR ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENTS- IN SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE THE AVERAGE RENT
IS- WELL OVER THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH- A DEVELOPMENT
COMPANY KNOWN AS STAR CITY BUILT
CO HOUSING UNITS. AVERAGING TWO
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET AND RENTED
THEM FOR FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH LESS THAN HALF
OF THE CITY'S AVERAGE RENT.
THESE NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE UNITS ARE IDEAL FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T QUALIFY FOR
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING BUT- CANNOT
COMPETE FOR MARKET RATE
APARTMENTS. WHAT WE REFER TO AS
THE MISSING METAL. THE CO
HOUSING MODEL CAN ALSO BE USED
TO HOUSE SENIORS AND FORMERLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS SINCE
COMMUNAL LIVING PROVIDES A
UNIQUE MIX OF BOTH PRIVACY AND
THE ABILITY FOR COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. UNFORTUNATELY LOCAL
RESTRICTIONS THAT REQUIRE A
MINIMUM UNIT SIZE OR A MAXIMUM
DENSITY HAVE MADE IT DIFFICULT
TO BUILD COAL HOUSING
APARTMENTS. AB SIX EIGHTY TWO
WILL ALLOW CO HOUSING PROJECTS
TO QUALIFY FOR INCENTIVES UNDER
THE DENSITY BONUS LAW AND HELP
MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER OF UNITS
WITHIN AN ALREADY COSTLY PARCEL
OF LAND. THE MEASURE WILL
REQUIRE DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN EXCHANGE FOR
CONCESSIONS AND INCENTIVES SUCH
AS INCREASED DENSITY. AB SIX
EIGHTY TWO WILL HELP DIVERSIFY
THE HOUSING STOCK. OFFERING BOTH
NATURALLY OCCURRING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THE OPTIONS FOR
COMMUNAL LIVING. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS JANE
BLUMENFELD A SENIOR FELLOW AT
UCLA'S CITYLAB. OKAY WELCOME-
JAMES BLOOM BLUMENFELD. YEAH
WELCOME THANK YOU HAVE A CHAIR
NEXT THANK YOU HAVE A NO YES I
THINK SO YEAH MY NAME IS JANE
BLUMENFELD IN A FELLOW THAT-
CITY LED UCLA. CITY LAB UCLA IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO AND WE THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MAN FOR HIS EFFORTS ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. HELLO WELL
DOCUMENTED HOUSING CRISIS
REQUIRES MANY SELECTIONS THERE
IS NOT A SINGLE FIX WE ALL AGREE
ON THAT. THE STATE NEEDS
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE EFFECTIVE
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR PUBLIC
DOLLARS. AND WE NEED A VARIETY
OF HOUSING TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN
HELP PEOPLE AFFORD TO BLINK AND
BE PROFITABLE ENOUGH SO THAT
PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESS OF
BUILDING HOUSING WILL ACTUALLY
BUILD. AB SIXTY TO CREATE A NEW
HELPING TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS NOT
BEEN LEGAL FOR MANY REASONS.
DOWNING AND OTHERWISE. AB SIXTY
TWO WILL ALLOW DEVELOPERS TO
BUILD CO HOUSING APARTMENT
BUILDINGS. THAT COMPLY WITH
LOCAL HI GLORIA SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS. BUT TO GIVE
DEVELOPERS THE ABILITY TO BUILD
SMALLER UNITS THAT INCLUDE A
BATHROOM SINK REFRIGERATOR
MICROWAVE. KITCHENS AND DINING
SPACES WILL BE SHARED AMONG THE
RESIDENTS- HELPING BUILDINGS CAN
BE LOW RISE ARE HIGH RISE. WHICH
SPEAKS TO THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. IT SIXTY TWO A
REALLY APPROPRIATE FOR SENIORS
BECAUSE KITCHEN ARE HAS FOR
ELDERLY PEOPLE. AND BECAUSE
COMMUNAL DINING TOLD REPORTERS
ON NEED FOR THEM AND THERE'S
VIRTUALLY NO HOUSING THAT IS
EVEN REMOTELY AFFORDABLE FOR
SENIORS OTHER THAN INCOME
RESTRICTED HOUSING. THIS TYPE OF
GIRL HOUSING AUTHORITY ATTRACTED
TO STUDENTS AND YOUNG PEOPLE
NEARLY IN THE JOB MARKET WHO ARE
WILLING TO SHARE CONTENT IN
EXCHANGE FOR LEICESTER. ASSEMBLY
THAT NUMBER BALLOONED THAT
MENTIONED THE STARKEY PROJECT IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAT IS BUILT ON
THE EXACTLY TO THE
SPECIFICATIONS OF AB SIX EIGHTY
TWO. AND THE ONE THING I WOULD
ADD ABOUT THAT PROJECT WAS WHEN
IT FIRST OPENED THE BILL THE
BUILDING WE STEP IMMEDIATELY AND
HAD A WAITING LIST OF EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE. I DON'T THINK
WE NEED TO WORRY ABOUT GETTING.
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE POPULATION
RECORDS HOUSING UNITS THAT CAN
MEET DIFFERENT NEEDS. FOR
SENIORS YOUNG PEOPLE DIDN'T CO
HELPING OFFERS THE RIGHT BALANCE
OF PRACTICING AFFORDABILITY AND
COMMUNITY. AT SEKALI. I THOUGHT
. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS BERMAN FILLED- I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE ON OPPOSITION TO SPEAK ON
THE BILL IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE AUDITORIUM. I WOULD LIKE T
SPEAK OF THEM OPPOSITION OKAY
SING NINE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION- YOU ARE US HIS ME
OPERATOR- WE CAN HAVE THOSE COME
IN I WANT THEM JUST TO STATE
THEIR NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND
THE POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. I
WILL TAKE BOTH SUPPORT FOR AND
OR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO
STATE YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL
A. B. SIX EIGHTY TWO. PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE. KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO HAVE
TWO LINES IN Q. WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE THIRTY SIX THREE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
MARVIN NORMAN PROBLEMS EVER
AGAIN- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALL. NINE FORTY TWO FOUR TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
pIS RYAN JOE A CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIAN BE SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER CALLERS IN THE
QUEUE. NOT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. YES
REPORTER. FIVE YES I THINK YOUR
FAMILY MEMBER EVAN- I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU AND YOUR SPONSOR
WORKING SO HARD ON A CO HOUSING
AND SOMETHING I REMEMBER
LEARNING AT A PLANNING
COMMISSIONER CONFERENCE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND IT'S REALLY
HELPFUL NOT ONLY FOR SINGERS BUT
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT
AFFORDABLE WAYS TO LIVE SO I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THAT ASPECT
OF THE BILL I DO HAVE CONCERNS
AROUND MAKE ENSURING THAT SOME
OF THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
GUARDRAILS AROUND THE MISUSE OF
THE DENSITY BONUS. PART BUT I
SEE THAT YOU'VE MADE ADJUSTMENTS
FROM- THE STUDENT DORM HOUSING
BILL FROM LAST YEAR YOU'VE
ALREADY MADE SOME OF THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS SO- WELL I RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE NO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS AND I AM HAPPY TO
SPLIT THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY WHO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. TO MOVE. A MOTION THANK
IT AND A SECOND SO WE HAVE MUCH
FROM OVER ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I THINK
SPRINT INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THE MINUTES OVER. OF THE INTERIM
I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A MULTI YEAR
PURSUIT FOR YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO FINDING
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO EASE OUR
HOUSING CRISIS I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY MCDONALD PLEASE. CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AGUIAR-CURRY HI.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI LACKEY VOTING.
PACKAGE NOT LOADING BLOOM. I
WELL I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI ALMOST.
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS I ROBERT RIVAS II
VOEPEL THANK VOEPEL HI. OKAY
WELL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR-
MISSING MEMBERS AND WE HAVE A
VOTE. WE HAVE A WE HAVE A SEVEN
YEAR BILL VIA GREAT THANK YOU DO
YOU WANT ME TO PROCEED WITH-
FILE ITEM SIX A THE NUMBER IF
YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO TAKE
MISTER SALAS BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
WAITING. AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE ROAD ARE YOU OKAY THAT
ASSEMBLY YOU KNOW WHAT MR SUMMER
BLOOM YOU JUST OFFER YOU THE
OKAY. IN ORDER TO BE SO NICE TO
STILL THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
WE LIKE EACH OTHER. ALWAYS LIKE
EVERYBODY IS FOR THE POLICY WE
HAVE DIFFERENT. YOU KNOW WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU AGAIN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE PROUD
PRESENTS ASSEMBLY LITTLE BILL
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
CRUSADE THAT MOTION THE SECOND
AB PLEASE PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE ONE SIX FOUR FOUR MOVE
BARRIERS TO THE CREATION OF
EXCESS VERY. FALLING UNITS AN
ADDITIONAL BEDROOMS IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE ENSURE THAT AT
YOU CREATION IS STREAMLINED AND
THAT. AND THAT MORE BEDROOMS CAN
BE CREATED IN THE STATE WITHOUT
BEING HELD UP BY THE PUBLIC
HEARING PROCESS SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE THE
HEIGHT LIMITATIONS FROM SIXTEEN
TO EIGHTEEN FEET PREVIEWS. IN
ADDITION THE BILL WILL CREATE
PARITY. FORTY BEDROOMS WITH NEW
IDEAS AND GENERATING USE WHICH
ARE ALREADY EXEMPT FROM THE
PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS. THAT
INCREASES IS LIMITED TO LOTS
THAT HAVE EXISTING MULTI FAMILY
AND MULTI STORY STRUCTURES. AND
ALSO WOULD ENSURE THAT MULTI
STOREY EIGHTY YOU STRUCTURES ARE
NOT FORCED TO HAVE A SUB
STANDARD CEILING. HEIGHTS OF
LESS THAN EIGHT FEET.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL AIMS TO
ADDRESS THE LENGTHY PROCESS OF
PROPERTY OWNERS ARE OFTENTIMES
FORCED TO GO THROUGH IF THEY
WISH TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL BEDS.
TO THE EXISTING HOME. CREATING
PARITY FOR ADDITION OF BEDROOMS
WITH NAY NEW. AND GENERATE USE
WITHDRAWAL. EXEMPT FROM THE
PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS- I DON'T
MOTION OF AB SECOND I'LL JUST
SAY THERE'S NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I
DO HAVE. A ON THE PHONE
TESTIFYING REMOTELY AS KATE BELL
WITH CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION GREAT OKAY WE WILL
MOVE ON TO A CAVE BILLS
TESTIMONY PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATE FALLON BEHALF TO CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
SPONSORED THE BILL. AS WELL AS
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER L. A. I'LL BE BRIEF I
JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN'S MANY STAFF FOR
FEEDBACK ON LANGUAGE. AND WE
APPLAUD THE MEMBER BALLOT BOX
DURING EIGHTY NINE SIXTEEN WHICH
WILL STREAMLINE THE CREATION OF
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. LEADING
THE BURDEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
ESPECIALLY THE COBEN FIREMEN
WILL RESULT IN THE CREATION OF
MORE HOUSING MUCH MORE RAPIDLY-
TEND TO NEED MORE PACE FOR
GROWING FAMILIES WHO DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO MOVE. THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ESTATE WILL ALL BENEFIT FROM
THIS BILL. AND AGAIN THE HEIGHT
LIMITATION IS ONLY FOR. MULTI
FAMILY MULTI STORY SITES
ALREADY- BUT THIS WILL HELP TO
BUILD TWO STORIES IT'LL PREVENT
US FROM HAVING TO DIG DOWN
SOMETIMES. AND IT WILL ALSO HELP
IN CONVERTING PEAKED ROOF
GARAGES AND KATIE IS. ALL THESE
POLICIES WILL HELP OUR MEMBERS
AND OTHERS DELIVER MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STATE
RESPECTIVELY. AFTER I'VE- THANK
YOU FOR MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISSPELL- DOING HAVEN'T
MISSED KHAN IS WELL TODAY OR NOT
. NO A IT TESTIFYING FOR THE-
OKAY SO THAT'S FINE SO WE WILL
JUST HAVE THE- THE SUPPORT. AND
YOU HAVE NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AT THIS APPOINTMENT
WILL OPEN THE PHONE LINES TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND OR
OPPOSITION- OPERATOR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO OPEN UP THE LINES.
REMEMBER JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON A
BEAM NINE ONE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOU HAVE THREE
LINES IN Q. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE THIRTY SIX THREE SIX. I
HAVE BARBARA NORMAN COMMITTEE
ARRESTED- FONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALL. BLIND THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE. IF THE BALLOT ARE
QUITE ALIKE PLAY A PUBLIC
APPEARANCE ON BEHALF OF SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. LINE. FORTY TWO FOUR TWO. FIND
FORTY TWO YOU'RE OPEN FOR
COMMENT. THANK YOU HAVE A- NOW I
CAN'T. GREAT THANK YOU FIVE
RIGHT ENJOY CALIFORNIAN B- IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. WITH
THAT COLONEL FOR THE LINES IN Q.
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S MOVE
ON TO OUR THE ANY- QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE YES. WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
. GOOD DONE- FIVE YEARS. THE
GETTING THERE WE'RE GOING TO GET
A THERE ARE MAKE MORE MOTIONS I
KNOW- SO AS WE NEVER SAYS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING THIS FOR
AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR NEED- ARE
YOUR DESIRE TO ARMS YOU KNOW
MAKE SURE THAT THE MAIN HOUSE
AND THE EIGHTY IS FALL UNDER THE
SAME LAW WELL WHEN I READ YOUR
BILL AND PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M MISTAKEN- NOT ALL CITIES
HAVE A ZONING REQUIREMENTS OR A
PUBLIC HEARING REQUIREMENT. FOR
ADDING A THIRD BEDROOM WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE CITIES IS THAT
JUST IRRELEVANT FOR THEM OR IS
THAT EXPERTS IN THE BILL THAT
THEY'RE EXCLUDED FROM THAT PART
OF THE PROVISION SO WE'RE
FINDING WE INTRODUCED THROUGH
MADAM. AT THE END OF THIS BILLS
WERE FINDING SOME DRASTIC. OF
INSTANCE LIKE OUT IN BURKE THEY
HAVE. HAD THESE ORDINANCES THAT
THEY WERE CREATING OUT FOR
SOMEBODY JUST WANTING TO BUILD
AN ADDITIONAL BEDROOM ONTO THEIR
EXISTING HOUSE. RIGHT AND THEN
THE WHOLE HEIGHT REQUIREMENT O
THAT WE SAID OKAY WELL. ONLY IF
IT'S A TWO STORY BUILDING
ALREADY IF YOUR HOME IS ALREADY
TWO STORIES. AND WALAU THAT TOO
SO WE GOT AROUND THAT. SO MY
WHOLE THING WAS YOU KNOW LIKE IF
PEOPLE ARE TO. WEATHER SAY YOU
EXPANDED YOUR FAMILY ARE YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE IN AND LAW. OR
MAYBE NOW BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF
IT YOU'RE TAKING AN- ADDITIONAL
FAMILY MEMBER BECAUSE OF OTHER
HEALTH. HEALTH THE- HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE
THAT ABILITY TO DO THAT TO YOUR
OWN HOME. AND SO THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION IS AIMED
AT TO ALLOW THAT FLEXIBILITY FOR
HOMEOWNERS. TO BUILD OUT WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH. A HUGE
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS BECAUSE
SOME JURISDICTIONS SO FOR
INSTANCE LIKE BERKELEY AND SOME
OTHERS. THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
PUTTING IN THESE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS. WRITING WE KNOW. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A WHOLE POLITICS
AROUND THAT BUT WE JUST WANT TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO DO THAT WITH
THEIR OWN HOMES. HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY. AND SO WE DON'T
WANT THAT TO TRIGGER. YOU KNOW.
MULTI JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE WILL TRY TO BE A
LITTLE PREEMPTIVE HERE. AND
ACTUALLY HELP THE STATE WITH THE
HOUSING CRISIS AS WELL. SO THE
LIGHT OFF A BY CITIES NONE OF
THEM. A BEDROOM. SO THEY WOULD
BE UNAFFECTED BY THAT PORTION OF
YOUR BILL CORRECT. WELL ISN'T
THAT LUCKY FOR YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. OTHER THING
THEN WE HAVE A MORE SIMPLY WAS
FROM A FAMILY MEMBER RIVAS A
SECOND BY MISTER LUCKY I BELIEVE
FROM WRONG- WELL. YEAH I THINK
WE ARE. WE ARE MOTIONS- AUTHOR I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS YOU KNOW
THANK YOU FOR WORK WITH MY
COMMITTEE DURING THE INTERIM. TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL I
BELIEVE THE CHANGES ARE YOU'RE
PROPOSING TO EIGHTY YOU LAW ARE
REASONABLE AND I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. MOTIONS
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS THE PAST
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
LACKEY AYE. THAT'LL AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM HI BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI RAMOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL. HELLO HI ALL RIGHT I CAN
REMEMBER THE CAPITAL FORM KEEP
THE ROLE OF ENTERING IT ARE
MISSING MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT LET'S
SEE HERE- IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABLE TO CERVANTES MISTER LIVING
HERE. WELCOME MR LEVINE. COME
JOIN US. IN A BEFORE WE GET
STARTED I JUST WANNA SAY I WANT
TO COMMEND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE DURING THE INTERIM
THEY WORK REALLY HARD WITH ALL
THE MEMBERS TO HELP GET THEIR
BILLS THROUGH AND TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE APPROPRIATE MINIMUM SO
AGAIN. THANK YOU TO THE ENTIRE
TEAM FOR WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
DURING THE INTERIM. ALL RIGHT.
I'M NOT GONNA TRY TO ARRANGE
THEM DON'T EVER DON'T EVER TRY
IT. REALLY BAD. YOU CAN BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE REQUIRES A
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS A
DELICATE SUB REGION OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
CONSIDER EMERGENCY EVACUATION
ROUTE CAPACITY WILDFIRE RISK SEA
LEVEL RISE AND OTHER IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IN ALLOCATING
HOUSING NEED IN THEIR
METHODOLOGY FOR THE RENO PROCESS
COMING DISASTERS IN THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN OUR STATE
HAVE MADE MORE MORE PLACES
UNSAFE TO LIVE WELL CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE MAKES IT PRONE TO FIRES.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CAUSED- YOUR
AND WORST DISASTERS AND EVER
BEFORE- WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
RISK OF FLOODING- THAT WILL
IMPACT US AS WELL AS C. LEVEL
RISE. AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THESE IMPENDING IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND DISASTERS
ON RISK TO RESIDENTS. WHEN
PLANNING FOR ADDITIONAL HOUSING
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WE DO
NEED A WHOLE LOT MORE HOUSING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WILL NOW- DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION YOU KNOW THAT ARE
COMING TODAY OKAY. OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE ALLIANCE
FOR US- FOR THOSE THAT MAY WANT
TO CALL IN. AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING
JUST FOR THE NAME THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION ON
THIS BILL. TO SHARE YOUR
POSITIONING B. ONE FOUR FORTY
FIVE. ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
NINE THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO. IT'S
GOING ABOUT INFORMING PEOPLE. WE
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. INCLINE
THIRTY SIX THREE SIX WELCOME-
YEP MARMORATA COMMITTING A
RESIDENTS LOUNGE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER. FOR
THE LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. OKAY THEN WE WILL MOVE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS A
SECOND BYE BOERNER HORVATH-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHTTIME
SORRY- OKAY- I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORD AND YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS
SO IMPORTANT FOR ME AS WELL AS
SO MANY OF US BECAUSE WE BOTH
REPRESENT DISTRICTS EXPERIENCE
EXTREME LOSS OF. OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY IS THE RESULT OF RECENT
WILDFIRES AND IS A PLAN FOR MORE
HOUSING IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS OF WILDFIRES AND OTHER
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
DISASTERS. I'M YOUR BILL
INSURERS ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL BE A KEY
FACTOR IN FUTURE PLANNING FOR
HOUSING I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY WASHES DO PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SECRETARY. THAT IS THE CLOSE
THAT'S THE BEST CLOSER THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR YES. MOTIONS TO PASS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
BLACKIE. LACKEY NOW BLOOM. WILK
HI BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI RAMOS RAMOS
HI THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT RIVAS I
WILL TELL THAT STORY. VOEPEL
ABSTAINED OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ONLY THE ROLE OPEN I THINK
OPEN YOUR BILLS OUTSIDE AT THANK
YOU I'M DISCUSS WITHOUT THE
CHARITY'S THINK SOMEONE COULD
FALL OVER- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NO REAL WORLD- DO WHEN UNION
DUES ON THAT OR WHAT. YOU KNOW I
. THE SERVICE. OKAY- I DON'T NOT
SEE MISS MOMENTOUS SHE HERE NO
SO WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND
MISTER BLOOM WILL BE PRESENTING
FOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
THE NOT AS CUSHY. GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN THAT MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M SURE HE
APPRECIATES THE EFFORT OF A
STAFF ON A DRAFTING UP THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND WORKING UP THE
BILL. CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE
HOUSING SHORTAGE CALLS FOR
POLICIES THAT INCENTIVIZE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO HELP MEET THE STATE'S
CALLED BUILDING MILLIONS OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A AB NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR TO INCENTIVIZE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CLOSER TO COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES. THE MEASURE WHICH
SUNSETS THIS JANUARY GAVE
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENTS BONUSES
FOR CONTRIBUTING TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ONE WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND
THE SUNSET DATE TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. BY
REINSTATING COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT BONUSES AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ONE WILL ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ACQUIRE MORE
REVENUE FROM COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES AB HELPED THE STATE
ADDRESS THE HOUSING SHORTAGE. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT IS OFFERED FOR SALE.
A PARTNER AT SHEPPARD MULLIN.
THANK YOU HAS SOME RIVER BLOOM-
MR FRANCO IF YOU'D LIKE TO JOIN
US. OPERATOR. LINE IS OPEN. THE
OFFER FREE HOME IT YOUR
CALIFORNIANS. I APOLOGIZE NO
RESPONSE ON THE LINE AT THIS
TIME OKAY WE CAN MOVE ON I
BELIEVE- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. YOU TO STATE
YOUR POSITION ON THIS BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE THIRTY ONE
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MIGHT HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. LINE.
THIRTY SIX THREE SIX. YEP MARC
MEDINA ROAD AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL LINE IN Q. AND BE
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO
TO THAT LINE NOW LINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LYLE DOTSON
FROM THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT CANNELLA NO FURTHER ALIGNED
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
ON THE BILL. SEEING NONE OF THE
ENTERTAINING MOTION. SECOND OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION BY- MYSTERONS
AND THE SECOND BY MR- RIVAS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO HE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PRESENTING FOR HIM
TODAY AND- WITH THE AMENDMENT TO
INCLUDE A CENTS A DAY WE SO WE
CAN FURTHER EVALUATE THE PROGRAM
FOR ALWAYS SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES. SECTOR MENTAL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I. LACKEY. LACKEY
HI BLOOM I BOOM HI
BOERNER HORVATH. BOERNER HORVATH
HI RAMOS RAMOS HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US HI ROBERT RIVAS
RIVAS I WILL TELL. HELLO HI OKAY
pMUCH FOR PRESENTING FOR MR
SANTIAGO. ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
ON AND I BELIEVE THERE SHE IS
WELCOME. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES SHE IS PRESENTING ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
WHICH WILL CREATE AN INDEPENDENT
CITIZENS COMMISSION FOR
RECYCLING BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
BEGINNING WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY
ROUND EVER DISTRICT TEAM HELLO I
DO WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
EIGHT THROUGH TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS AND JUST WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK. I WILL
GET TO THE POINT I HEARD THAT
HOMEOWNERSHIP HIM A SECOND. I
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT. IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR THERE IS A
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
VOTED FOUR TO ONE TO ADOPT THE
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICT MAP. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ROUND OF
REDISTRICTING THAT FRACTURES THE
LATINO COMMUNITY IN THE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE DILUTING THE
COMMUNITIES VOTING POWER IN
THEIR CAPACITY TO ELECT
REPRESENTATIVES OF THEIR CHOICE.
THIS FAILURE TO PROTECT VOTING
RIGHTS AND COMPLY WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW ILLUSTRATES WHY AN
INDEPENDENT CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION IS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED TO DRAW FAIR
MAPS RIVERSIDE COUNTY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
SPEAK. FOR YOUR BILL OKAY-
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR THOSE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO- WAY IN PRO SUPPORT-
OPPOSITION- JUST STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SHARE POSITION ON
THE BILL MAN PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IF YOU HAVE ONE LINE WITH AN
OPERATOR TO BE JUST A MOMENT
OKAY. WE CAN ACT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD LINE THIRTY SIX THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOR THE
NORFOLK EVERYTHING ALRIGHT THEN
I'LL GET YOU THE BALL CARE SONGS
OF COURSE. THANK YOU. WE ALSO
HAVE LINE TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THERE THIS IS INTERVIEWED
PRESSURE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
ONE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
COLONEL FOR THE LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
C. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER FELL YES
I HAVE A- I HAVE A QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR AND THEN A COMMENT
DEPENDING UPON THE ANSWER IF I
MAY MADAM CHAIR YOU MAY SO-
POINTS FOR LEX THESE PEOPLE. SO
IT IS ACTUALLY OUTLINED WITHIN
THE ANALYSIS IT'S- QUITE LONGER
BUT I CAN GO THROUGH THAT FOR
YOU. THE AYE COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL A SELECT SIXTY OF THE
MOST QUALIFIED APPLICANTS AND
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT RELEVANT
REQUIREMENTS AS OUTLINED WITHIN
THIS BILL. AND THERE ARE MANY
PROHIBITIONS AS WELL THAT ARE
ALSO OUTLINED WITHIN THE BILL
AND THE ANALYSIS. VERY WELL MAY
I MAKE MY COMMENT YOU MAY THESE
ARE NOT ELECTED PEOPLE THEY'RE
NOT. AND MY MAIN CONCERN IS. ANY
NINE RULE THAT'S NOT OUT OF
FOURTEEN SEVEN OR SEVEN WORK AND
HANG UP OR ANYTHING ELSE SO IT'S
A STACKED DECK OF CARDS FOR
RIVERSIDE- THE FOR. NONE
POLITICAL PEOPLE N. P. P. AND
THIRD PARTY. FOUR COMMISSIONERS
THEY'LL BE CHERRY PICKED. SO. IF
YOU HAPPEN TO BE A REPUBLICAN.
WHICH I HAPPEN TO BE. YOU'RE
DEAD THIS IS A STACKED DECK THIS
IS JUST SIMPLY. SETTING IT UP TO
BE COMPLETELY CONTROLLED. FIVE
YEAH WHOEVER ANYWAY THAT'S MY
COMMENT- I JUST WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT THAT SOME OF US WERE
AWAKE. IF I COULD RESPOND MADDON
CHAIR YOU SURE CAN SO THE
OPERATION OF THE COMMISSION NINE
COMMISSIONERS CONSTITUTE A
QUORUM. NINE VOTES ARE REQUIRED
TO PASS ANY MOTION BY THE
COMMISSION UNLIKE THE STATE
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION THERE'S
NO REQUIREMENT ABOUT THE
PARTISAN MAKEUP OF AN
AFFIRMATIVE VOTE SO THE VOTE
REQUIREMENT IS ONLY NINE
COMMISSIONERS WITH NO
CONSIDERATION OF THE
PARTISANSHIP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT I HAVE A MOTION BY
BOERNER HORVATH ABSOLUTELY. AND
YOU HAVE A SECOND. ZERO SECOND
BY THREE OF US SUMMER
THREE OF US. OKAY AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN WOULD
CREATE A COMMISSION A BY
RETURNING THE POWER TO THE REAR
DISTRICT WHERE I BELONG TO THE
CITIZENS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE
COMMISSION WILL BE- CONSTITUTED
AS I MENTIONED FOR THE TWENTY
THIRTY ROUND OF REDISTRICTING WE
ALREADY DO THIS IN LA AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IT IS TIME
TO I SET THIS FOURTH AND THE
FOURTH LARGEST COUNTY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL AND
DYING THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND I WILL BE VOTING
I'VE TODAY. MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SECRETARY MCDONNELL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY HAI
BLACKIE NOPE BLACKIE NO BLOOM.
HI WHO AM I BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I MOST RAMOS HI
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS HI
ABOUT. VOEPEL NOW OKAY- YOU
BILLS OUT. YEAH SO THANK YOU
MUCH HOME NOW DO. THE BILL OKAY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE
ABSENT VOTES RIGHT NOW. OKAY.
BILL SB SIX SEVENTY TWO WHICH IS
CRISTINA GARCIA AT THE CARDS VIA
. US SECRETARY. THANK. THE
PROGRAM. WE'RE GONNA TAKE. SB
SIX SEVEN TWO OFF THE CALL. HI
YEAH CARNAP MEMBERS
BOERNER HORVATH NOT NOTING.
RAMOS ALMOST I LOOK BILL SB SIX
SEVEN TWO IS OUT. OF WILL NOT DO
IT SB SIX EIGHTY TO BLOOM. AT
THE MEMBERS PROMISED. RAMOS HI
MOST- THE BILL IS OUT. NEXT
WE'LL DO IT AB EIGHT NINE ONE
SIX FOLLOWS. AS A MEMBERS RAMOS
. ALMOST I HAD THE BILL OUT.
OKAY I THINK WE HAVE ALL TAKEN
CARE OF I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU TODAY FORGETTING AND I SOME
PROMPT THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
WILL SEE IN A COUPLE WEEKS OR
MAYBE A MONTH. THANK YOU. I'VE
BEEN IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY. HELLO.